i want you know what i want to be
for real i decided this the other day
i want to be religious i want to be a
guy who's like uh uh
like believes in god
and just goes to church sometimes
and but it's like one of those cool
dudes that's like yeah you know you
don't have to believe in god but i do i
don't want to have to push it on you and
[ __ ] but i want to have i want to
believe in something man i've been
thinking about this the other day and i
told my friends and they laughed dude
and it was funny but i
i meant it dude it is funny to hear me
say that but also i mean it i wish there
was something
you know that i could uh
believe in like a higher power you know
and there is
there are like my friends or my family
you know something that's greater than
myself that i can i can i can rely on
and that can help me and those are
that's my family that's my my crew you
know um
but
it sucks because no matter how much i
want to believe in god there's always
that thing
that there where it's like
okay i want it to be proven and then
people are like but hey dude that's what
faith is and i'm like that
just can we get a little bit of proof
though right
can we get a little bit of proof though
can one day jesus just be like and you
look over and it's jesus and then he
goes and you're like
okay i well
okay i have faith i have faith and then
religious people will be like but that's
not faith though because you saw jesus
and then you'll say stuff to like
religious people like well i've never
seen jesus and then i'll be they'll say
some annoying ass [ __ ] like well can you
see air but you know it's there
and you're just like jesus christ okay
i can't talk to you
but all of these feelings how could you
feel all these feelings without a jesus
how could you feel all of these feelings
without a higher power and you know what
dude maybe and i'm not the guy who's
like no no no no there's no jesus or
there's no god i should stop saying
jesus there's different relig uh
religions there's no god
right
i i can't say there's no god
how the [ __ ] do i know who the [ __ ] do i
think i am to know about that whoa he's
starting off hot
but i want to be religious hey dude
i want to jump in the lake
right
i want to put all my clothes in and jump
in the lake
and i have another man pet my head
i guess i'm just not there yet man
i hope i am
really cause you see religious people
around and they're [ __ ]
you know they got their their battles
and [ __ ] but they walk around and they
know
something else is out there and maybe
it's not but they know it is
and that's good enough for them dude
and here's the other thing man
i never really believed in heaven
because
my idea of heaven is you get there and
you chill and you have a good time
there's a lot of turkey sandwiches
people give you massages mostly women
and you're just kind of [ __ ] watching
a bunch of tv that doesn't really matter
right not like important shows like
[ __ ] in the lexicon like game of
thrones like you're watching fear thy
neighbor
or you know some dumb documentary that
has four episodes about like game stop
you're watching that
but kristen's idea of heaven is not that
it's like there's there's we're not
watching that
she's like scrolling through tick tock
and like
the house is decorated in a way that i
don't want it to be
so how the [ __ ] are we going to be there
together
don't husbands always want to be in
heaven with their wives i mean probably
not but i do
so what is it
say you got eight kids and you love all
of them but two of them hate you you
want them in heaven they don't want to
be in your heaven
so then what
but i want to believe it dude
my buddy said to me one time
you know because a lot of people are
like well when you get to heaven you get
to have all the the women you want and
all the sex you want and then my buddy
said dude when i get to heaven i want
that sexual urge removed from me i want
to be stress-free and i was like that's
the ticket dude
that's the ticket man that's my heaven
but i don't really believe in heaven and
i want there to be a heaven dude
but that's the thing about religion even
if there is no heaven who's it hurting
besides all the [ __ ] wars and [ __ ]
you know what i mean besides the people
literally dying and [ __ ] like literally
being [ __ ] shot and burned and
[ __ ] cut off their heads and all the
wars through all of humanity besides
that the day-to-day [ __ ] of it when
you're running into a religious guy he's
not a piece of [ __ ] he's just living his
own life smiling
it's a very convoluted and intricate
thing to think about at least for me man
but i'm a dumbass
i just wish there was something out
there that i could [ __ ] really get
behind man you know and it's my kid
right
but he's real i can see him right there
i don't know
it's just what i've been thinking of
lately man
you know
[Music]
crazy
crazy
[Music]